nous sommes chez cookies l'entreprise
montréalaise qui se spécialise dans le
prêt-à-manger et le prête à cuisiner est
en pleine expansion on s'en va dans un
magnifique
quartier Vieux-Port en janvier elle
déménagera son siège social dans de
nouveaux locaux mais ils ne seront pas
plus grands bien au contraire on passe
du 12 mai on tombe dessus 4500 pieds
carrés mais ça va nous coûter à peu près
la même chose avec des employés qui sont
maintenant en télétravail la plupart du
temps cookies a choisi de réduire la
taille de ces espaces de bureau
l'entreprise qui traîne un immeuble qui
a grandement besoin d'amour pour un
édifice plus prestigieux si j'ai
vraiment pour améliorer l'expérience
employée c'est le premier truc c'est
d'offrir quelque chose d'invitant
d'accueillant que les gens ont vraiment
le goût de venir une tendance qu'on
observe à plus grande échelle les gens
échangent deux pieds carrés dans un
immeuble ordinaire
un pied carré dans un immeuble de
catégorie supérieure avant qu'on
s'aimait plus aujourd'hui on consomme
l'adoption massive du télétravail a
causé un tremblement de terre dans
l'univers des tours à bureaux dans le
quartier des affaires leur taux
d'inoccupation à doubler depuis le début
2020 pour passer de 9 à 18 %
ces 2e au centre ville de Montréal vous
avez l'équivalent de trois fois le 1
place du mari qui s'est libéré et les
bureaux continuent de se vider lorsque
leur beau généralement de 5 ou 10 ans
arrive à échéance de nombreuses
entreprises se délestent de l'espace
qu'elles ont en trop ce qu'on observe
c'est une réduction en moyenne de 20 à
30% des surfaces louées le marché actuel
est donc à l'avantage des locataires
pour les attirer dans leur immeuble les
propriétaires doivent en donner plus
c'est une compétition c'est un marché
ouvert alors pour que choisissent
d'aller dans un édifice versus l'autre
il y a un propriétaire qui va dire mais
moi je suis prête à te donner 100
dollars de pied carré pour que tu
puisses t'aménager dans mes locaux et je
vais te donner peut-être 12 sinon 24
mois de loyer Galactus dans ce contexte
les immeubles moins bien situés ou qui
se font vieillissant seront délaissés
nous avons voir des rénovations et nous
avons déjà vu ça avec quelques immeubles
ici à Montréal c'est une nouvelle
réalité pour les propriétaires alors
qu'ils avaient le gros bout du bâton
avant la pandémie avenue Miguel carlodge
ce bureau pour t'en occuper par une
entreprise était pratiquement désert
lors de notre passage
si la firme camperelle qui gère
l'immeuble comme de nombreux autres à
Montréal malgré tout son patron se
montre plutôt optimiste il y en a
certains qui ont dit bon on ferme
complètement nos bureaux simplement pour
économiser mais il y en a d'autres qui
disent non on va louer dans les
meilleures immeubles les meilleurs
le nettoyage ou le comptoir à sandwich
qui était à l'intérieur de la tour à
bureau sont les premiers à vraiment
souffrir de cette de cette absence de
travailleur là mais globalement les
commerçants tiennent bon si on prend la
rue Sainte-Catherine qui rend la colonne
vertébrale centre-ville plusieurs
détaillants nous rapportent à voir des
ventes similaires ou même supérieures à
2019 la vitalité du centre-ville repose
de plus en plus sur sa population locale
et elle est en pleine croissance de 2016
à 2021 le nombre de résidents à grimper
de 17% dans l'arrondissement Ville-Marie
pour atteindre près de 105 000 personnes
le centre-ville de Montréal a connu la
deuxième plus forte croissance
démographique dans tout le Canada
uniquement au centre-ville la hausse est
de 40%, jamais les résidents du
centre-ville pourront à eux seuls
combler une perte d'achalandage que ce
soit de travailleurs de visiteurs à
l'inverse je vous dirais est-ce que
centre-ville pourrait vivre sans ces
résidents